all right guys we need a big old party
in the Las Vegas ballpark don't we we
need to get back in there we need to
have something I know Oh wake it up
shake it up
all right the winds are gonna shake us
around a little bit today guys so just
please be aware of that beautiful blue
skies lots of sunshine we're in the 70s
now
not too many neighborhoods have a taste
of the wind yet but that will change as
we get through the day and especially
later this afternoon and that's also
when the heat will be around and dry
conditions we're dry already to start
out with and then those winds will just
help dry out some more we'll get back
into those upper 90s close to 100
degrees at 99 today for Las Vegas and
you can see triple digits popping up
along the Colorado River Valley so we're
looking at about 25 mile-per-hour winds
in the lower elevation in the valley 99
for the high when 103 is normal for July
first we'll get the triple digits back
no real big hurry here
we'll keep it breezy tomorrow again red
flag warnings today because of the high
winds low humidity dry gusty winds and
for the fourth of July mother nature
we've got our own fireworks show planned
at a hundred and five on Saturday 107
Sunday and 108 on Monday